[Music]  the world is a mysterious place  [Music]  there are marvels of nature just waiting  to be discovered by those who are daring  enough to look mara was like the  creature I had only heard existed in  legend a mythical monster straight out  of your worst nightmares with Wild Eyes  in a hideous face and feet that were  amazingly freakishly  it's a terrifying creature with perfect  white teeth and breath that just smells  all minty fresh and only hair if it has  on its entire body is on the top oh  you're scaring up hey don't be scared  it's look it's just a story  everyone knows that the small foot isn't  real oh that's nice real nice way to  scarm for life  [Music]  [Music]